i mean i don't know about that
like so many guys be out there in the
world making sure women have everything
they want but who like how many girls
are going out of their way to make sure
a guy has everything they want wait what
does he mean by a woman's wants are
irrelevant i think the top 10 percent
the woman's wants are irrelevant because
that top 10 man has options right and
therefore
um if she wants certain things and
certain things for example um he can
just go to the next scale that is just
as beautiful will do exactly what she's
doing for him
and
at that moment her wants are irrelevant
i understand that
so are you saying to the top 10 men you
can see why because having so many
options where your wants as a woman
would be irrelevant i don't agree with
it oh yeah i understand it okay okay i
understand that yeah because you want
him more than he wants you anyway
but i mean average man's wants is
irrelevant to you
no
i didn't say that no i'm telling you it
is
why would you say that because she
wouldn't she wouldn't even see the
average man her average man is an above
average man
are you talking about average men yes
okay like average men's what because
okay if you're talking about right so
the guys that has everything or let's
say
you get what you've got yeah like that
sort of the average guys once doesn't
matter to women it's never mad like i
don't care if he wants me
you ain't having me i've got i've got my
man like what i'm saying like you do not
care about what i want like i agree but
i also think women do this thing of like
seeing potential as well
i want to do the whole i can fix him and
like build him up and
do do you think do you think i'm sorry
how do you see potential when someone's
like you've never spoke to you like you
just see them one day and then you start
like
you say hello
and i'm just saying that you just see
the potential right there so you've
never been there you've never
you've never been at that potential
potential yeah
i think every woman at some point i
think i think it's a lie to say you
haven't like i i can't i don't know you
personally like i just met you but i
think it's a lie like women do see
potential say you meet someone you talk
to them for 15 minutes oh
you know you you can get a vibe off of
someone oh oh i think they can do like
this or it doesn't matter what you think
if they're not actually hit if they're
not actually doing that i mean
this is enough
it doesn't mean that i fell for the game
but i'm just saying that women do fall
for potential yeah but eight times out
of ten women are going for potential
even if like the guy is worthwhile he
can treat me like crap because i know he
doesn't mean it or i know he's gonna do
better someday it's always like some day
or the next thing yeah women i'm telling
you women see potential in things
so you always say i was going to say
like you know some men will literally
just like tell you what you want to hear
so like the potential you're seeing is
just a facade to like how are you seeing
potential when he's most likely acting
like
not only that would you go for the man
with potential when the other guy that's
that's already there is chasing you as
well
i think it goes along the lines of
attraction so like
no you're you're a misunderstanding
and i think the best way i can explain
is say if i'm with someone and i am more
attracted to him than the guy that was
chasing after me and i am attracted to
him or we like vibe on some kind of
level and he's not he's not up to par
and it's like oh i'll keep going for
this because at some point he's not
going to do like this at some point he's
going to be better that's what i meant
when i said that i mean like
i mean like what do you mean he's not up
to par